hey listen I think you should buy a Wii
U in 2014 I know I know but let's relax
for a minute it's natural to be
suspicious and things aren't exactly
looking rosy for Nintendo's latest
tablet meets console thing the one
that's barely powerful enough to run a
bath and the machine 2/3 of the world
still just thinks as an add-on for the
original Wii yes that one just think
about buying one ok let's be honest
nobody is buying a Wii U because it's
their heart's desire to play an inferior
version of Call of Duty ghosts with
hobbled online modes the third-party
support for this machine is in a really
bad place but the Wii U has a trump card
that the ps4 and the Xbox one just don't
have it's home to first party Nintendo
games Nintendo games are wonderful they
are and look of course I'd rather
Nintendo took a few more risks when it
came to new I feel fancy new titles but
when int endo is on top of form it's
better than 100 Xbox one and PlayStation
4 launch lineups combined nak believes
the Wii U has Super Mario 3d World which
is phenomenal easily one of the best
platforming games in years and if you
think you're too cool for Mario games
then I'm sorry but we can't be friends
elsewhere there's Pikmin 3 which is
definitely worth upon't and The Legend
of Zelda Wind Waker HD is an incredible
restoration of a classic there's also
the wonderful 101 which has some really
fiddly moments but hey it's still better
than Ryze and yes I've only mentioned a
handful of games so far but there's some
more games coming in 2014 so far we've
got Donkey Kong Country tropical freeze
Mario Kart 8 super smash brothers for
Wii U and Bayonetta 2 all on the way
seriously Bayonetta 2 Platinum Games
might be about as commercially
successful as trying to flog Christmas
crackers in June but Bayonetta 1 was
beyond brilliant and I'll be that on day
1 for the sequel I think the current
$300 price tag is far too off-putting
but there's absolutely no way that price
isn't going to come down before
holiday season because if Nintendo
doesn't do it officially the retailers
will and the Wii U's main gambit is
still the gamepad I mean it's not gonna
be the specs is it this controller lets
you play games away from the TV and
occasionally features some bits in games
where you've got to slide your fingers
around it it feels big bulky and to
plasticy and boy i can tell you the
thing needs charging more than I would
think possible but this is a company
still able to work wonders with the
hardware I cannot fathom how anyone can
take a peek at Super Mario 3d World in
action and not think it looks like
everything good in the world distilled
into a single disc of bounding glory it
looks great and just imagine what they
could do with the upcoming Zelda game it
feels like long-standing gaming fans are
relishing the opportunity to kick the
company when it's down and that's crazy
I think steel diver sucks as much as the
next guy but I would absolutely hate to
live in a world without Nintendo in it
the Wii U is by no means an essential
machine but quality software is starting
to trickle in and nobody else makes
games quite like Nintendo
I'd rather install Skynet on my PC then
allow a future where Nintendo ends up
churning out something as atrocious as
the 2006 reboot of Sonic the Hedgehog
and if that means buying a Wii U in 2014
then I'd best get my credit card